Yeah,
Ray Kurzweil and I've met ray several
times.
He's a super good guy.
I like him a lot and I'm glad he's out
there doing it.
In this sense,
I'm not skeptical in a cynical way.
I hope that those singularity people are
wrong.
No,
I hope they're right.
I hope he does it.
I hope he lives forever because that
means I may have a shot at it,
whatever that would even mean living
for.
And so when,
when people like ray say to me,
Schermer Schermer don't you want to live
500 years,
a thousand years,
you know,
it's like,
listen,
I'm 63,
just get me to like 80 without,
you know,
my brain going crazy and I'm losing my
mind and Alzheimer's and senility and
you know,
get me to 100 without cancer and you
know,
give me a 120 without being bedridden.
Know just one step at a time,
one problem at a time.
That's how progress really happens
incrementally.
Slowly.
I'm not this grand.
Let's aim for Utopia.
I mean aimed for it.
Fine,
but,
but just take it one step at a time,
you know,
cancer,
there's like 50 different cancers that
kill people.
Just tackle them one by one.
Heart disease,
Alzheimer's,
and senility.
You just solved those problems.
And because we know that the human body
is so complex that if you live to 150 or
200,
there may be other things that happen.
We don't even know yet.
I mean,
most people 500 years ago had no idea
about Alzheimer's other than the handful
of people that seem to have lost their
memories.
But,
you know,
now we realize because most of so many
of us live that long.
Okay.
So that's the problem with um,
uh,
with that is,
is it's too utopian in their thinking.
Just incremental steps.
And then second,
um,
my,
my skeptical,
skeptical alarms always go off when the
chief proponent of an idea that's going
to be the next big thing always says
it's in our generation.
You know,
every religious leader and cult leader
in history is always said it's going to
happen now in our generation,
all the way back to Jesus who said there
are some standing here before me now who
will not see the end of a time before I
return.
Okay.
So,
uh,
and,
and we're still waiting,
you know,
so,
when ray said it's going to happen in
2014 within our lifetime,
ray,
what if it's 2140?
I know you're gonna you're,
you're doing all the blood cleansing
one,
but you're not going to make it,
you know,
like another century now and,
and,
but even so,
what if it's 31,
59,
30 1:40 a thousand years from now.
I mean that's possible,
but you know,
you and I aren't going to be here to
enjoy,
you know,
why sell it like it's got to happen in
my lifetime because that always to me,
seems like you're just tickling that
part of the brain,
that religions like to tap in that,
that sort of egocentric.
It's all about me and I want to continue
on in the future.
I get that,
of course I do too,
but um,
but all the more reason we should be
skeptical when that idea on the table
being offered to us is,
feels too good to be true.
It almost always is.
Not Always,
but usually,
uh,
and so,
and there's hardly anything bigger than
offering in portrait and mortality or
the afterlife because.
Good.
So here's the problem.
When we are all aware that death is
real,
because we see all around us,
$100,
billion people have lived before us.
They're all gone.
Not One of them is come back.
Not even Jesus in my opinion,
but that's a different video.
Um,
and yet you can't,
you cannot conceive of what it's like to
be dead.
Because if I asked you,
picture yourself dead,
what do you see now?
Most people say,
well,
I see myself there at the funeral and
the coffin and you know,
my loved ones are,
you know,
hopefully grieving and there,
right?
No,
you wouldn't see that.
You wouldn't see anything because to see
anything,
you have to be conscious to conceive of
anything.
You have to be a,
you had been,
you have to be conscious,
and if you're dead,
you don't have any of that,
you're,
you're just really.
Death is just nothing.
And,
and the whole idea of the afterlife is
fairly new.
I mean,
the ancient Hebrews,
their idea of the afterlife was nothing.
You're just,
just nothing.
You're just gone.
That's it.
There's no place to go with angels and
flowers and whatever.
It's just nothing,
you know,
all that was added on centuries later
and uh,
you know,
and probably for socio political
reasons,
you know,
offer the peasants something nice so
that they'll keep building our pyramids
or whatever,
you know.
So,
um,
you know,
again,
we can't conceive of what it's like to
be done and yet we see it all around us.
So this creates something of a paradox
that we have to resolve in our minds.
Most people resolve it by thinking,
well,
I'm not actually going to die.
I'm just not gonna do it.
I'm going to live forever or I'm going
to accept Jesus or whatever and I'm
going to heaven.
You okay?
Yeah,
but what if you're wrong?
That's,
you know,
it's not a,
it's not a Pascal's wager where you can
say,
well,
I've nothing to lose and everything to
gain because which religion and their
version of the afterlife is the right
one.
Which one are you going to pick?
Well,
the Christians were the right ones.
Yeah,
well,
there's a billion Muslims who disagree
with you.
You know,
they don't accept Jesus as a savior.
They don't think he was even the
Messiah,
the son of God.
Okay?
So now what?
You know and they believe just as
strongly as you do.
So what if your God is the wrong one?
You're your version is the wrong theory
and they have the right one.
You pick,
you wasted your whole life investing on
this idea and you turned out to be
wrong.
Why not jettison the whole idea entirely
and appreciate the here and now because
that's all we have.
Whatever is in the hereafter,
here and now is what we have.